Mesdames et messieurs, nous commençons
notre descente vers Rome, nous pourrions connaître
des turbulences, de grandes turbulences, mon
préféré, détendez-vous et arrêtez de
serrer les poings.
pendant un an
quand j'avais ton âge, c'était peut-être
ma rue exacte, elle vient de rompre avec
son petit ami et je lui ai dit qu'elle pouvait
rester avec nous, tu ne vois pas la situation
qui est pleine de périls belle
drôle sexuelle intelligente Monica ton nom est
J'ai toujours quand je l'ai finalement fait, c'était très
proche de mon futur beau-père
Michel-Ange se sent très profondément à propos des
travailleurs que le toboggan devrait prendre à
Washington modèle vous ne pouvez pas partager deux ou
plus ouais ouais pas d'enfants un communiste le
père est un entrepreneur de pompes funèbres pour la mère
tu vois tu as toujours l'habitude de voyager pour le travail
n'est-ce pas agréable d'être quelque part pour le
plaisir